Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
大家好，我是 Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先快速向大家介绍一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师 Lisa Johnson 发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，这些原则都同样适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
挑战中还有由 Lisa 本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent 博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. with Dr. Marianne Durant Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Thank you for listening. So if you are listening to this podcast, then it's probably quite likely that you are aware that certainly for clinical psychologists, application season at the time that I'm recording, which is January 2022, is in, you know, in part of its cycle, part of its lifespan. So people are currently awaiting to find out if they are going to be offered interviews for the clinical doctorate. And I
如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南吧。我是 Marianne Trent 博士，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。感谢你的收听。如果你正在听这期播客，很可能你已经知道，至少对于临床心理学家而言，在我录制这期节目的 2022 年 1 月，正处于申请季的周期中。所以，人们目前正在等待是否会收到临床博士课程的面试邀请。我
would love some insider info about the life cycles, the application cycles of your particular discipline. So if you're listening to this and you're thinking, well, ours isn't, you know, September until spring, then let me know, because it's obviously important that I'm providing content that feels useful for you, whatever discipline of psychology you are in. So if you have a different time span, let me know. And I can make sure that I'm putting stuff in my diary, you know, planning content that's going to be useful for you at the time that you need it, because I don't want this to be just for aspiring clinical psychologists. I want this to be useful for you, whatever your particular niche goal is in psychology. And if you are
很想了解你们各自学科的生命周期和申请周期。所以，如果你正在听这期节目，并且心想：“我们的申请季不是从九月到春天”，请告诉我，因为我提供的内容对你所在的任何心理学学科都有用，这一点非常重要。所以，如果你的时间跨度不同，请告诉我。这样我就可以确保在我的日程表中安排好，规划出在你需要时对你有用的内容，因为我不希望这仅仅是为有抱负的临床心理学家准备的。我希望无论你在心理学领域的目标是什么，这期节目都能对你有所帮助。如果你正在
awaiting the news about whether you are being invited for selection tests or um for um for interviews themselves then you know all my heart goes out to you it is tricky um and by the time this goes live which is probably going to be February or March um you know that that time will be all the more closer and you might well be getting probably not letters these days. Will it be probably be interviews being communicated to you via email? the waiting, hoping, the wishing. Yeah, you know, and reflecting on every word you've written in your form and thinking, you know, is it good enough? Is it going to be okay? And even, you know, the experiences that you have in the days, weeks and months, even after you have clicked submit on that form, you're thinking, oh, this would have been submit on that form you're thinking oh this would have been
等待关于是否受邀参加选拔测试或面试的消息，那么我的心与你同在。这确实很棘手。等到这期节目上线时，大概是二月或三月，那时离结果会更近，你可能已经收到了通知——虽然现在可能不是信件了，大概是通过电子邮件通知面试吧？那种等待、希望、祈盼的感觉。是的，你会反思申请表上写的每一个字，心想：“这足够好吗？会没问题吗？”甚至在你点击提交申请表后的几天、几周甚至几个月里，你还会想：“哦，如果表上写了这个会更好……”
great on the form this would have been great and let's hope that you don't need to reflect on that in future forms but of course it can take a number of attempts and beyond to to get to you know and I was just talking to someone from the express actually a journalist to get to, you know, I was just talking to someone from the Express, actually a journalist to get to manifest what it is that we want, you know, and that's what we are trying to help you do in this podcast. We're trying to help you to manifest your dreams, you know. And my stance, you can probably Google it by the time you're listening to this, but my stance on that is that, you know, by goal setting and being quite focused and determined around what it is that you would like to achieve, it makes it a whole heap more likely that you're going to bring
希望你以后不需要在未来的申请表中反思这些。当然，这可能需要多次尝试才能实现。我刚才其实正在和《快报》的一位记者交谈，谈到如何实现我们想要的目标。这正是我们在这期播客中试图帮助你做到的。我们试图帮助你实现梦想。我的立场是——等到你听到这期节目时，你可能已经谷歌过了——通过设定目标，并围绕你想要实现的目标保持专注和坚定，你实现目标的可能性会大大增加。
that goal to fruition. You know, whether or not you want to add any crystals into the mix is entirely up to you. And people who like manifesting often do like a bit of crystal healing and all of that jazz. But, you know, by goal setting and tuning into the right podcasts ones with jingles you're gonna make it more likely for yourself that you are able to um you to achieve your dreams and achieve your goals so that's my little take on what we are that's my little mission for this podcast that this helps you know flavor the water that you swim in with um you know qualified psychology opinion um and i hope that you're finding it useful yeah so um i digress as i um uh want to do and i hope that you don't mind the fact that i digress because hopefully the stories are interesting along the way um if you don't like the fact that I digress, because hopefully the stories are interesting along the way.
至于是否要在过程中加入水晶，完全取决于你。喜欢“显化”的人通常也喜欢水晶疗法之类的东西。但通过设定目标并收听正确的播客（那些有片头曲的），你更有可能实现自己的梦想和目标。这就是我做这期播客的小小使命，希望它能用专业的心理学观点为你所处的环境增添色彩。希望你觉得它有用。是的，我跑题了，我总是这样，希望你不介意，因为希望这些故事在过程中是有趣的。如果你不喜欢我跑题……
If you don't like my digressing and you wish it was just pure psychology, then you might like to listen on double speed. Or, you know, maybe I'm not. Maybe I'm not your jam. I'm quoting Princess Poppy again. So when I was an aspiring clinical psychologist, I was having to wait for letters to drop through my letterbox to invite me for interview or to decline me from an interview and I remember the first time I was offered an interview for a doctorate course I sat on the stairs at my parents' house and I ripped it open and the first thing I saw was a map and I was like, oh my gosh, they don't send maps to people that they don't want to see. And so I just felt really excited from seeing that map. And, you know, I think that's a bit of a sad thing about moving to online communication because, you know, you'll know as soon as you open it you know
如果你不喜欢我跑题，希望内容纯粹是心理学，那你可能想用两倍速收听。或者，也许我不是你的菜。我再次引用了《魔发精灵》里 Poppy 公主的话。当我还是一个有抱负的临床心理学家时，我不得不等待信件投递到我的信箱，看是否邀请我面试或拒绝我。我记得第一次收到博士课程面试邀请时，我坐在父母家的楼梯上拆开信，第一眼看到的是一张地图，我心想：“天哪，他们不会给不想见的人寄地图。”看到那张地图，我感到非常兴奋。我认为转向在线交流有一点遗憾，因为……
there's no there's no how thick the envelope is to you know about how much information you're getting because you don't know how big the email is before you open it so um yeah that's a that's a downer for modern technology um because when you got a slightly fatter envelope that felt pretty exciting so yeah fond memories of that and I still have my letters offering me I think interviews on the course that I accepted and I still definitely have my letters offering me places on both of the courses that I was offered because that is, you know, really a significant milestone in my, in my life. You know, you knowing me now, like you do, you're probably like, did you buy a perfume? Did you buy some shoes? No, I decided to go off traveling. Where did I go? I went around India with one of my friends who was also getting on to a doctorate course. And also before that, I went to Spain and Morocco.
你一打开邮件就知道结果了，没有那种通过信封厚度来判断信息量的感觉，因为在打开之前你不知道邮件有多长。所以，这是现代科技的一个缺点。因为当你收到一个稍微厚一点的信封时，感觉非常令人兴奋。所以，我对那些信件有美好的回忆。我仍然保留着我接受的课程的面试邀请信，也绝对保留着我收到的两个课程的录取通知书，因为那是我生命中非常重要的里程碑。你现在了解我了，可能会问：“你买香水了吗？买鞋了吗？”没有，我决定去旅行。我去哪儿了？我和一位同样考上博士课程的朋友环游了印度。在那之前，我还去了西班牙和摩洛哥。
So that's what I did. And I'm afraid a pandemic has squashed people's ability to be able to jet set as much as they did. But once I knew that I was on the doctorate, I was making plans to jack my job in and to go and enjoy, you know, this stage of my life where I knew what the next stage was going to be and when it was going to start. I do believe it started on September the 22nd. So I just had to make sure I was back in the country for then. And, you know, I did. I think I got back from India on the Friday. I had my leaving party on the Saturday. I moved on the Sunday and my doctorate started on the Monday.
这就是我所做的。恐怕疫情已经压制了人们像过去那样四处奔波的能力。但一旦我知道我被博士课程录取了，我就开始计划辞职，去享受我生命中的这个阶段，因为我知道下一个阶段是什么，以及它何时开始。我相信它是 9 月 22 日开始的。所以我必须确保在那之前回到国内。我做到了。我想我是周五从印度回来的，周六开了欢送派对，周日搬家，周一就开始了博士课程。
So I was, you know, not leaving any time for living my life unlived. But then that said, I loved my doctorate as well. So it wasn't like it was a question of, you know, putting my life on hold. You know, I was committing myself to one locality for three years. But, you know, if you're listening to this, perhaps as a qualified psychologist or perhaps as an aspiring one or a trainee psychologist, and you're like, she loved her doctorate. What? Then I say, yeah, I did. You know, I knew it would be tricky in parts and in parts it was. I knew I'd be signing up to work and study. I knew I'd be, you know, having lots of different demands. But for me, I didn't have children at that time. And
所以我没有留下任何未曾体验的生活。但话虽如此，我也很爱我的博士生涯。所以这并不是说我把生活搁置了。我确实承诺在接下来的三年里专注于一个地方。但如果你正在听这期节目，也许你是一位合格的心理学家，或者是一位有抱负的心理学家，或者是一名实习心理学家，心想：“她爱她的博士生涯？什么？”那么我会说，是的，我爱。我知道它在某些方面会很棘手，事实也确实如此。我知道我是在报名参加工作和学习。我知道我会有很多不同的要求。但当时我没有孩子，
I was single when I started the course. It was what I expected it to be. And I had made space in my life to accommodate those three years. I didn't go into it thinking it was going to be effortless. And it wasn't. So I think sometimes going into things with our eyes open can be really useful. Once again, I've wobbled off, I've digressed. so if you are waiting for your own application season to start you might well be clicking and checking whether your references have been received and if they still say no then it might just be worth checking in with your referee it's always a good idea to check in with your referee before you submit to check that, A, they're not going off on some six month secondment or maternity or paternity leave, that their contact details haven't changed gently check in with them to explore you know whether they have been able to do that for you or whether um you know whether they need some more
开始课程时我还是单身。它正如我所预期的那样。我已经在生活中腾出了空间来适应那三年。我并没有认为它会毫不费力。事实也确实如此。所以我认为，有时睁大眼睛去看待事物真的很有用。我又跑题了。所以，如果你正在等待自己的申请季开始，你可能正在点击查看你的推荐信是否已收到。如果还没收到，那么联系一下你的推荐人可能是值得的。在提交申请之前，先与推荐人确认一下总是个好主意，确认 A：他们不会去休六个月的借调假、产假或陪产假，确认他们的联系方式没有变，温和地询问他们是否已经为你完成了推荐，或者他们是否需要更多
time or some more i don't know more something from you or maybe they just need a little a little jig maybe um the reference requesters are just sitting in you know in spam folder or something and they've not seen it um so with you gently getting in contact to probe, it might make that come to fruition that bit quicker. I, in the days of the Stone Ages, used to wait for my own little stamped address envelope to arrive that said references received. So the course would send those out
时间，或者是否需要你提供更多信息，或者他们只是需要一点提醒。也许推荐请求正躺在垃圾邮件文件夹里，他们没看到。所以，通过温和地联系来询问，可能会让事情进展得更快。在石器时代，我曾等待着我自己的贴好邮票的回邮信封寄回，上面写着“推荐信已收到”。所以课程组会寄出这些，
or Clearinghouse would send those out or clearinghouse would send those out um at my own cost of a stamp stamp stamped addressed envelopes we called them in the day um yeah to let me know that a my application had been received that's a happy one to receive although i knew because i'd already stalked it on royal mail um and b that references have been received and then it was like okay we are good to go let's just wait and see and hope and wish okay so a useful piece of advice here is when you and if you hopefully are called to interview it can be a really good idea to look at your own application to look what you submitted.
或者 Clearinghouse 会寄出这些。我自费买了邮票，我们当时称之为“贴好邮票的回邮信封”。是的，为了让我知道 A：我的申请已收到（收到这个很开心，尽管我知道，因为我已经在皇家邮政网站上追踪过了），以及 B：推荐信已收到。然后我就想：“好的，我们准备好了，让我们拭目以待，希望并祈祷吧。”好的，这里有一个有用的建议：当你——如果幸运的话——接到面试通知时，回顾一下你自己的申请材料是一个非常好的主意，看看你提交了什么。
And any bits that make you cringe a bit, you know, maybe you're thinking, I might slightly have padded out my own expertise and knowledge in that area. It's a good chance for you to be able to try and thicken that dialogue a little bit between now and your interview date. For any of you watching The Apprentice, I do believe I've watched every single series and every single episode. I, yeah, I just love it. You know, we all know that the most cringeworthy episodes
任何让你感到尴尬的部分，你可能会想：“我可能稍微夸大了我在那个领域的专业知识和经验。”这是一个好机会，让你在面试日期之前尝试加深那方面的对话。对于任何观看《学徒》节目的人，我相信我已经看了每一季的每一集。我真的很喜欢它。我们都知道最令人尴尬的环节
are the interview ones where their CVs are turned over and they've got in contact with people and, you know, they've been ousted as actually having not done some of the things they've got in contact with people and, you know, they've been ousted as actually having not done some of the things they've claimed to have done or they've bigged up their part and it's just horrifying. So just try to make sure that what you've put on your form, in retrospect, in hindsight, is factually correct as possible. And I don't know of anyone who goes to the extent that Lord Sugar and his team do. But yeah, just have a look
就是面试环节，他们的简历被翻出来，面试官联系了相关人员，他们被揭穿并没有做过他们声称做过的事情，或者他们夸大了自己的作用，这简直太可怕了。所以，尽量确保你写在表格上的内容，事后看来，尽可能符合事实。我不知道有谁会像 Sugar 勋爵和他的团队那样去核实。但是的，看看
over what you've submitted, because of course, that's what you've been invited on the basis of. Okay, so once you've had a look at what you've said, if you do feel like there's any weaknesses, any drawbacks that you feel might be your Achilles heel, then I said it's your chance to um you know to get as much experience um so that it doesn't feel like you're going into that interview with an Achilles heel um we all will have Achilles heels we might not know what they are until they answer ask us the question and then we're like oh man I have no clue um Just take a breath. Just take a pause. You can always ask for a moment as you feel like your world is imploding and there's tumbleweed and crickets. You can always ask for a little more time, you know, and you can always ask them to repeat the question again, because what we know is when we are in a, you know, excited forward slash agitated, anxious state, the top part of our brain might go offline a little bit.
你提交的内容，因为当然，你就是基于这些内容被邀请面试的。好的，看完了你所说的内容，如果你觉得有任何弱点或缺点，你觉得可能是你的“阿喀琉斯之踵”，那么我说过，这是你的机会去获得尽可能多的经验，这样你就不会觉得你是带着“阿喀琉斯之踵”去面试的。我们每个人都有弱点，我们可能直到他们问我们问题时才知道那是什么，然后我们会想：“天哪，我毫无头绪。”深呼吸。停顿一下。当你觉得世界正在崩塌，周围一片死寂时，你总是可以要求一点时间。你总是可以要求他们重复一遍问题，因为我们知道，当我们处于兴奋或焦虑的状态时，大脑的前额叶可能会暂时“下线”。
So taking those breaths can be really useful and just encouraging yourself to calm down. And it's OK to ask for the question again. Okay so you might find it helpful to go through in supervision your form if that is the kind of relationship you have with your supervisor and to you know to think about any questions that crop up for them. Yeah they might already have read your form anyway but if they haven't then it might be useful if you can bear it, if you can tolerate it, to explore some of that in supervision. And your next port of call will be for whatever job you're applying for, be it, you know, an assistant psychologist post or research psychologist post or indeed one of the clinical doctorate courses or your own um you know um qualified specialty route um then you
所以，深呼吸真的很有用，鼓励自己冷静下来。要求重述问题是可以的。好的，如果你和督导的关系允许，在督导过程中过一遍你的申请表可能会有帮助，去思考他们可能会提出的任何问题。是的，他们可能已经读过你的表格了，但如果还没读过，如果你能承受的话，在督导中探讨一下这些内容可能会很有用。你的下一个目标将是你申请的任何工作，无论是助理心理学家职位、研究心理学家职位，还是临床博士课程，或者是你自己的专业资格路线，那么你
need to be looking at the job description you know so it might be an idea to look at what the course themselves are saying about their program um if you are an aspiring clinical psychologist it might be useful for you to get yourself um a copy of the alternative handbook to look at what the other trainees on the course are saying about the course and if you are applying for an NHS job then there'll always be a person description and of course a job description so make sure that you know what they're asking for because they could ask you know about any of those things and I'm obviously in this podcast I'm not going to be giving any past examples of questions because that's not really appropriate I don't feel um and so yeah if you were tuning in hoping that that's what I was
需要查看职位描述。所以，看看课程组对他们项目的描述可能是一个好主意。如果你是一位有抱负的临床心理学家，获取一份《替代手册》（Alternative Handbook）来看看其他学员对课程的评价可能会很有用。如果你正在申请 NHS 的工作，总会有个人说明和职位描述，所以确保你知道他们要求什么，因为他们可能会问到任何这些内容。显然，在这期播客中，我不会提供任何过去的面试题示例，因为我觉得这不太合适。所以，如果你是抱着这个目的来收听的，那么抱歉，剧透一下，
going to do then sorry spoiler alert um that's not going to be here. I'm sure if you Googled some, some would come up. But yeah, it doesn't feel particularly fair for me to do that. And of course, with my knowledge of the two clinical doctorate interviews that I've been, it wouldn't feel particularly fair to broadcast that in case they're still using the same sort of questions just wouldn't it just wouldn't feel it wouldn't feel like it was particularly fair it'd be like giving you the exam questions before the exam so I'm sorry I'm not going to do that but I want you to do your best and to be your optimal best self and to have to scrabble in in a session like I probably did you know with those tumbleweed moments, but managing your own
这里不会有这些内容。我相信如果你谷歌一下，可能会搜到一些。但我觉得这样做不太公平。当然，以我对那两次临床博士面试的了解，广播这些内容会让我觉得不公平，万一他们还在使用同样的题目呢？这就像在考试前把考题给你一样，所以我很抱歉，我不会那样做。但我希望你尽力而为，展现出最好的自己，即使在面试中像我一样遇到尴尬的时刻，也要管理好自己的
physiology enough to be able to get through it and to pull the rabbit out of the hat and get yourself that job. So those are our basic checks to make. It can be also helpful to Google the names of anyone that you know who's going to be interviewing you so that you can read any research that they might have done recently or to see what service they work in and kind of the way that the way that their service operates if you are applying for a specific trust then it can be useful to google where there's any trust values that are around for your trust. So they might be things like, you know, compassion in action, respect for everybody, you know, safety.
生理状态，足以支撑你完成面试，并像变魔术一样拿出最好的表现，赢得那份工作。所以这些是我们要做的一些基本检查。谷歌一下面试官的名字，阅读他们最近发表的研究，或者看看他们所在的部门以及他们的服务运作方式，也是有帮助的。如果你申请的是特定的信托机构（Trust），谷歌一下该机构是否有价值观也是有用的。它们可能是：以行动体现同情心、尊重每一个人、安全等。
I don't know, it differs between trusts. But if you know a specific trust, not so much for clinical interviews because it's not the trust that are interviewing you. It's usually academic staff and clinical staff from the locality. So, you know, it might be that actually on some doctorate courses that there is a representative from the trust who's going to be employing you. But to my knowledge, I'm not familiar with that.
我不知道，不同信托机构之间会有所不同。但如果你了解特定的信托机构，对于临床面试来说，这并不那么重要，因为面试你的通常不是信托机构，而是来自当地的学术人员和临床人员。所以，可能在某些博士课程中，会有雇佣你的信托机构的代表在场。但据我所知，我不熟悉这种情况。
So if actually that is the case, let me know and I can make sure that we reflect that in future so yeah perhaps if you're going on to a pwp or an assistant psychologist or some other kind of related job you know support worker and you're going to be looking at trust values then it can be really useful to make sure that in every answer you give that you're weaving in you know a trust value as well so if they're asking something about confidentiality, then you could give, you know, your usual patter about what confidentiality is and why it's important. You could give a little case vignette about where you've used confidentiality or how you've explained it. And then you could, you know, weave in a relevant
所以如果确实如此，请告诉我，我可以确保在未来反映这一点。所以，如果你正在申请 PWP（心理健康从业者）、助理心理学家或其他相关工作（如支持工作者），并且要查看信托机构的价值观，那么确保你在回答的每一个问题中都融入这些价值观是非常有用的。如果他们问到关于保密性的问题，你可以给出你通常关于什么是保密性以及为什么它很重要的套话。你可以给出一个简短的案例，说明你在哪里运用了保密性，或者你是如何解释它的。然后你可以融入相关的
trust value of, I don't know, respect for everyone and, you know, clinical excellence or, you know, weave in a relevant trust value of, I don't know, respect for everyone and, you know, clinical excellence or, you know, whatever the trust values are. But you need to be making sure you're giving a values based interview. So, yeah, I hope that is useful. Always look out for who is employing you and what is important to them and try and quote it back to them in interview because that's going to help you stand out. the same is true of course for for the clinical courses if they are specializing in you know cbt then it makes sense to be mentioning cbt if they are really dynamic or systemic or you know any other kind of discipline then it makes sense that you talk the talk and walk the walk okay i'm just going to take a short break um and i will be back to think with you more about um interviews um hold fire and
信托价值观，比如“尊重每一个人”和“临床卓越”，或者无论信托价值观是什么。你需要确保你进行的是一场基于价值观的面试。所以，希望这很有用。一定要留意谁在雇佣你，什么对他们很重要，并尝试在面试中引用这些，因为这会让你脱颖而出。对于临床课程当然也是如此，如果他们专注于 CBT（认知行为疗法），那么提到 CBT 是有意义的；如果他们非常注重动力学或系统论，或者任何其他学科，那么谈论这些内容也是有意义的。好的，我要休息一下，稍后回来和你一起思考更多关于面试的问题。请稍等，
i'll look forward to speaking to you very soon If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. My name is Diakolola Amujam. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that
我期待很快与你交谈。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。书中充满了能帮助你获得资格的课程和经验。所以来看看吧。它就在这本书里。这是《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。我叫 Diakolola Amujam。我是一名来自爱尔兰的心理学应届毕业生。我也是一名有抱负的临床心理学家。Marianne 博士的书《临床心理学家集体》在我的临床心理学家成长之路上非常有帮助。当我计划在英国继续研究生学习时，我发现这本书
this book provided in-depth information on the UK D-ClinSci application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and trainee clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favourite part of the book, as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified.
提供了关于英国临床心理学博士（D-ClinSci）申请流程的深入信息，这非常有用。我喜欢阅读合格的临床心理学家和实习生的经历。各种叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不同，它为临床心理学之旅提供了惊人的见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为心理学家的人推荐这本书，让它成为你的指南。书中充满了能帮助你获得资格的课程和经验。
So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical psychologist collective it's january 2022 and we are most definitely still in pandemic season aren't we um and so certainly for 2020 and 2021, application and interview seasons looked a little different. They looked a bit like homeworking, didn't they? You know, quite often they took place via Zoom. Maybe they might have been shorter than would have been ideally. And it might mean that you don't see anyone who is also an aspiring psychologist during the interview process. It might just be you and the academic staff and you and the clinical staff. Whereas actually,
所以来看看吧。它就在这本书里。这是《临床心理学家集体》。现在是 2022 年 1 月，我们绝对仍处于疫情时期，对吧？所以对于 2020 年和 2021 年，申请和面试季看起来有些不同。它们看起来有点像居家办公，不是吗？它们经常通过 Zoom 进行。面试时间可能比理想情况要短。这意味着在面试过程中，你可能看不到其他有抱负的心理学家。可能只有你和学术人员，或者你和临床人员。然而，
you know, a key part of the experience for me was sitting, you know, with however many people there were on the day in the waiting room and lunching together. So for me, oh, you know, when you do online training at home on Zoom, it's not the same, is it? Because you don't get the snacks, you don't get the lunch. And so if I was applying for a job, I would make sure that I bought myself, you know, an aspiring psychologist lunch. That's totally what I would do to make sure that I felt like, you know, yeah, I'm treating myself nicely here, but also gearing myself up to perform optimally. So in making sure it's not something that's going to make me really sluggish all afternoon, you know, and, you know, there's going to be ready for me to be able to grab it and eat it
对我来说，体验的一个关键部分是和当天面试的其他人在候诊室坐着，一起吃午饭。所以对我来说，当你通过 Zoom 在家进行在线面试时，感觉是不一样的，因为你没有零食，没有午餐。所以如果我在申请工作，我会确保为自己准备一份“有抱负的心理学家午餐”。这绝对是我会做的事情，以确保我感觉自己受到了很好的对待，同时也为最佳表现做好准备。确保它不会让我整个下午都昏昏欲睡，而且当我准备好吃饭时，它就在那里。
when I'm ready to eat it. So, oh, I can't stand fridge cold sandwiches. So I'd probably have to text my husband and say, take the sandwich out of the fridge or whatever I was eating or a salad so that it wasn't too cold. But can you take care of yourself on interview day or maybe have someone else take care of you, your catering needs to look after you because it's a really stressful process because it really matters. You know, if you are striving to be a psychologist, then you're not doing this for kicks, you know, you're doing this because it matters to you. And so, yeah, can you help get someone else on board to look after you and to, you know, to make sure that you're fed and watered in a way that really helps you to thrive. And if there isn't someone, then you can
我受不了冰箱里拿出来的冷三明治。所以我可能会给丈夫发短信说：“把三明治从冰箱里拿出来”，或者无论我吃什么，沙拉之类的，这样它就不会太冷。但在面试当天，你能照顾好自己吗？或者让别人照顾你，你的餐饮需求需要有人打理，因为这是一个压力很大的过程，因为它真的很重要。如果你努力成为一名心理学家，你不是为了好玩才做这件事，你是为了它对你很重要。所以，你能找人来照顾你，确保你的饮食能让你茁壮成长吗？如果没有人，那么你可以
do that for yourself, you know, and maybe by the time we are, you know, in applications, whenever it is that you're listening to this episode, that face-to-face interviews are back on the agenda, in which case I hope that they are still doing drinks, refreshments and lunch, because that is just the highlight for me. That's like a bonus, you get a free lunch and an interview. Yeah, so bring on the snacks. I'm all about the snacks and the drinks. And actually way one of the ways I chose between which clinical course to accept was because one of them had given me a choice of herbal teas at interview day and I just thought these are my people these are my people whereas I think in the other one there was just black tea or coffee and I was like I don't drink either of those so clearly wasn't the only reason but it was certainly you know on my list of pros of the course that I eventually picked you know selection of herbal teas check so if I
自己做。也许等到你听到这期节目时，面对面面试已经重新提上日程了，如果是这样，我希望他们还在提供饮料、茶点和午餐，因为那对我来说简直是亮点。就像是奖励，你得到了一顿免费午餐和一次面试。是的，多准备点零食。我非常喜欢零食和饮料。事实上，我选择接受哪个临床课程的方法之一，是因为其中一个在面试当天为我提供了多种花草茶选择，我当时就想：“这些人是我的同类。”而另一个只有红茶或咖啡，我不喝那些。显然这并不是唯一的原因，但它确实在我最终选择的课程的优点清单上。所以，如果我
was having interviews at home I'd be making sure that the environment I was in was also kind of aspirational and kind of nice. So I might be lighting my favorite scented candle. I might be making sure that I was, you know, dressed properly for an interview, not just from the waist up. So I'd probably make sure that I had an outfit where I felt like a trainee psychologist you know so I'm trying that outfit on for size or I felt successful or worthwhile so of course I probably would be a little bit smarter for an interview than I would be for for you, a day on placement, for example. But I want something that helped me psychologically get on board with the fact that this was a really important interview day. This wasn't just me sitting in my slippers and in my joggers.
在家面试，我会确保我所处的环境也是令人向往且舒适的。我可能会点燃我最喜欢的香薰蜡烛。我会确保我为面试穿戴得体，不仅仅是腰部以上。我会确保我穿的衣服让我感觉像一名实习心理学家，我在试穿那套衣服，或者我感觉自己很成功、很有价值。当然，面试时我会比在实习期间穿得更正式一些。但我想要一些能从心理上帮助我进入状态的东西，让我意识到这是一个非常重要的面试日。这不仅仅是我穿着拖鞋和慢跑裤坐在那里。
OK, so for me, that's how I would make sure that I was in interview mode all day. But it's a big deal, you and I took I probably wear my um probably wear my my shoes in the house um on that occasion I took my um my kids to the cinema recently and in the back of the car my eldest said to me mummy I'm looking forward to going into the cinema because it makes me feel like a millionaire and I said oh what do you mean and he said well because I wear my shoes on the carpet and I was like oh what you mean because I make you take your shoes off at home and he said yes um but when we watch um old episodes of Topsy and Tim and stuff they wear their shoes all over the sofa and like on their beds and my kids are like appalled with that like mummy why have they
好的，对我来说，这就是我确保整天处于面试模式的方法。这是一件大事。我那天可能穿了我的鞋子在屋里走动。我最近带孩子们去电影院，在车后座，大儿子对我说：“妈妈，我很期待去电影院，因为它让我感觉像个百万富翁。”我说：“哦，什么意思？”他说：“因为我穿着鞋子走在地毯上。”我说：“哦，你是说因为我在家让你脱鞋？”他说：“是的。”但当我们看《Topsy and Tim》的老剧集时，他们穿着鞋子在沙发上，甚至在床上，我的孩子们对此感到震惊，说：“妈妈，为什么他们穿着鞋子在沙发上？”我说：“我不知道，我不知道。”
got their shoes on on the sofa and I'm like I don't know I don't know um so yeah I would be breaking my own rules um on interview day or getting myself some new shoes um so New Year's Eve I dressed up as um Dorothy from the Wizard of Oz and I did wear shoes in the house, but they were red ones and they'd never been worn outside. So that helped me feel that I was okay. And I probably didn't go on the carpet with them. I probably just stayed on the hard floor. So yeah, do you have your own weird little rules about shoe wearing in the house?
所以是的，我会在面试当天打破我自己的规则，或者给自己买双新鞋。新年前夜，我打扮成《绿野仙踪》里的多萝西，我在屋里穿了鞋子，但那是红色的，而且从来没在外面穿过。这让我感觉很好。我可能没穿它们走在地毯上，我可能只是待在硬地板上。所以，你对在屋里穿鞋有什么奇怪的小规则吗？
Whatever is okay for you is okay for you. But if you ever come around my house, please take your shoes off. So yeah, wear your shoes off so yeah wear your shoes on your carpet on the day of your interview because it will make you feel like a millionaire and that's direct from my eight-year-old who doesn't want to feel like a millionaire on the day of their interview so we need to be turning our phone off not just on silent so um i was just distracted for a moment there because my watch buzzed you know it told me to move my bum um so maybe turn that function off um and make sure that your phone's
无论什么对你来说是合适的，就是合适的。但如果你来我家，请脱鞋。所以，在面试当天穿上你的鞋子走在地毯上吧，因为这会让你感觉像个百万富翁。这是我八岁儿子的建议。谁不想在面试当天感觉像个百万富翁呢？我们需要关掉手机，不仅仅是静音。我刚才分心了一会儿，因为我的手表震动了，它提醒我该动动屁股了。所以也许关掉那个功能，确保你的手机
off and if you've got a dog maybe it's a good idea to see if anyone can look after the dog for the day so that you're not having to worry about walking the dog you can still walk yourself you can still do that on breaks um but you don't want to have to be worrying about the dog barking or distracting you if you are at the front of the house then it might be a good idea to draw the curtain so that you're not distracted by the postman and it might be helpful to you know we've all got deliveries arriving all the time these days so it might be helpful to see if you've got someone else on call or put a note on your door, sending any deliveries to your, um, to your neighbor. If you've got one, need to make sure that you are adequately hydrated. Um, it can be useful to have,
关机。如果你有狗，也许找人帮忙照看一天是个好主意，这样你就不用担心遛狗了。你仍然可以在休息时间遛自己，但你不想担心狗叫或分散你的注意力。如果你坐在房子前面，拉上窗帘可能是一个好主意，这样你就不会被邮递员分散注意力。而且，我们现在总是收到各种快递，所以如果有人能帮你代收，或者在门上贴个条，把快递送到邻居家，可能会有帮助。如果你有邻居的话。需要确保你摄入了充足的水分。
a glass of water with you in the interview. Um, but of course we do have a tendency as humans to use drinks as safety seeking behaviors and this was something that we observed in our professional personal development group at my own training is that people would tend to use having a slurp of their drink to pause for time and deflect questions so you know I would probably nowadays just try and own that a bit more and pause and take a breath and maybe even be explicit about whatever is going on for me as my internal processes um whereas in the past certainly as trainees we would pause and dominate the conversation with you know fiddling around with a bottle of water and all of that. And we made a decision that we wouldn't do that. We wouldn't bring drinks to sessions. Or if we did,
在面试中准备一杯水可能很有用。但当然，作为人类，我们倾向于把饮料当作寻求安全感的行为。这是我们在自己的专业个人发展小组中观察到的，人们倾向于通过喝水来争取时间并转移问题。所以现在，我可能会尝试更多地掌控这一点，停顿一下，深呼吸，甚至明确表达我内心正在发生的事情。而在过去，作为学员，我们确实会停顿，并通过摆弄水瓶来主导对话。我们做了一个决定，我们不会在会议中那样做。我们不会把饮料带到会议中。或者如果带了，
they'd stay under our chair so that we could try to stay as connected to the process as possible. So just be mindful if you are wanting to hydrate yourself all the time mid-interview. You know, it's okay to be nervous. You know matters it's a big deal um but yeah just think about how you're using your hydration um to to perhaps buy you time um and just be consciously aware of that i think and like i said you know it can be useful just to give yourself some breathing time to be able to slow down that tricky brain of ours and to be able to bring your a-game you know if our mind is racing if our thoughts are whirring a thousand miles a minute then we're not going to be able to think about what it is that we've got to do and what
它们会放在椅子下面，这样我们就能尽可能保持与过程的连接。所以，如果你想在面试中一直喝水，请注意这一点。你知道，紧张是可以的。这很重要，这是一件大事。但要思考你如何利用补水来争取时间，并对此有意识。就像我说的，给自己一些呼吸时间来减缓我们那个棘手的大脑，并发挥出你的最佳水平是很有用的。如果我们的思维在飞速运转，每分钟转一千英里，那么我们就无法思考我们需要做什么，以及我们需要
we've got to answer so just give yourself a pause you know take a breath before answering the question really think about your options and it's always okay breath before answering the question. Really think about your options. And it's always OK to ask for the question again, especially if you've done a big waffle and you want to make sure you've covered it. So if you know any trainee psychologists at the moment or you know any qualified psychologists, perhaps hopefully your supervisor, they might be willing to do a mock interview with you. And that can feel like a very cringeworthy exercise indeed. And I did that with my supervisor at the time who was a forensic psychologist and I was an aspiring clinical. But it just helped me to get those crickets moments and you know all of the tumbleweed moments where I just felt like a you know pretend human let alone an aspiring trainee clinical psychologist out of the way and you know just got me some of that ability to want to laugh at myself out the
回答什么。所以给自己一个停顿，在回答问题前深呼吸。真正思考你的选择。而且在回答问题前深呼吸总是可以的。真正思考你的选择。要求重述问题总是可以的，特别是如果你说了一大堆废话，想确保你已经涵盖了重点。所以，如果你现在认识任何实习心理学家或合格的心理学家，希望是你的督导，他们可能愿意为你进行模拟面试。这确实可能是一个非常尴尬的练习。我当时和我的督导做了这个，他是一位法医心理学家，而我是一名有抱负的临床心理学家。但这确实帮助我克服了那些尴尬的时刻，那些让我觉得自己像个假人，更不用说有抱负的实习临床心理学家的时刻。它让我学会了嘲笑自己，
way because I did that in the relative safety of my supervision relationship so it can be really helpful to have um to have yeah to have that and just to have someone ask you questions in an interview setting and kind of be a bit more, you know, stony faced with you. Because that can be really useful to help you feel that pressure. And then when you get to the actual interview experience, it feels less alien. And perhaps if you haven't been in your post that long, or you feel like your relationship is not that great with your supervisor, then you might not want to admit that you're going for a new job. So that might not always feel
因为我在督导关系的相对安全中做到了这一点。所以，有人能为你进行模拟面试，并表现得稍微冷淡一点，真的很有帮助。因为这可以帮助你感受那种压力。然后当你真正经历面试时，它就不会那么陌生了。也许如果你在岗位上待的时间不长，或者你觉得和督导的关系不是很好，那么你可能不想承认你要去申请新工作。所以这可能并不总是感觉
that approachable. But hopefully you might know someone who's got more experience with you than you. It might be a trainee or it might be someone who's already qualified but not your supervisor. And they might be willing to at least have a look through your application and have a look through the job description to come up with some example questions that might be useful for you to consider so i hope you found this really useful and there should be some time between when this episode goes live and when certainly the clinical application interview season comes to the fore. So if there are any specific questions you've got, then do let me know through my contact details of which you can find in the show notes and the links section. And I will,
那么容易接近。但希望你可能认识比你更有经验的人。可能是实习生，也可能是已经合格但不是你督导的人。他们可能愿意至少看一眼你的申请材料和职位描述，想出一些对你有用的示例问题。所以我希望你觉得这真的很有用。从这期节目上线到临床申请面试季到来之间应该还有一些时间。所以如果你有任何具体问题，请通过我在节目说明和链接部分提供的联系方式告诉我。我会，
you know, really be really happy to to help shape this and yeah thank you for listening I hope you find this useful and good luck with your interview. Being well supported during any interview season is so important I have therefore planned some compassionate question and answer support sessions for you. You are absolutely welcome to come along to all of them. Some of them, none of them. No need to book. And here are the dates for you.
你知道，我真的非常乐意帮助塑造这一点，是的，感谢你的收听，希望你觉得这很有用，祝你面试顺利。在任何面试季得到良好的支持都非常重要，因此我为你策划了一些充满关怀的问答支持环节。非常欢迎你参加所有环节，或者参加其中一些，或者一个都不参加。无需预约。以下是日期。
Monday, the 28th of February from 7.30pm. Monday, the 21st of March, 7.30pm. Monday, the 4th of April, 7.30pm, Monday the 21st of March, 7.30pm, Monday the 4th of April, 7.30pm, and Monday the 9th of May, 7.30pm. And they will all be live streaming via my socials, which includes Twitter, YouTube, LinkedIn, and Facebook. So you can absolutely pick your favourite platform and they'll all be available on replay as well. Hope you find it so useful and I will look forward to catching up with some of you then. Take care. your guide. With this podcast that you're set to be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book.
2月28日星期一晚上7点30分。3月21日星期一晚上7点30分。4月4日星期一晚上7点30分，3月21日星期一晚上7点30分，4月4日星期一晚上7点30分，以及5月9日星期一晚上7点30分。它们都将通过我的社交媒体进行直播，包括Twitter、YouTube、LinkedIn和Facebook。所以你完全可以选择你喜欢的平台，而且它们也都会提供回放。希望你觉得这很有用，我很期待到时候与你们中的一些人交流。保重。你的向导。有了这个播客，你离获得资格又近了一步。这是玛丽安·特伦特博士的《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我叫贾娜，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。
I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我觉得关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。各种不同的途径让我感到惊讶，成为临床心理学家并没有完美的路径，这让我充满了信心，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就放不下了。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。